et sachez que l'application stop
qu'ovide collecterait plus de données
que ce qu'avait annoncé le gouvernement
un chercheur a découvert que
l'application pour piler les
identifiants de toutes les personnes
croisées par un utilisateur
l'exécutif avait pourtant fermé que
c'est les personnes croisées à moins
d'un mètre et pendant 15 minutes
seraient pas concernés contacté par
mediapart le secrétariat d'état au
numérique ne remet pas en cause ses
révélations mais les justifie plutôt par
une nécessité technique pour en parler
en direct avec mme thomas forêt il est
pdg de walt heures monsieur forest
bonjour merci à d'être avec moi alors le
gouvernement nous a menti s'est il
trompé ou simplement n'avait-il pas le
choix alors moi je pense pas qu'ils nous
aient qui nous ait menti en revanche ce
sont des sujets compliqués c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que la techno qui a
déployé elle est clairement illisible
pour l'ensemble des concitoyens et il
sait pas nouveau la technologie c'est
toujours un sujet compliqué ils ont pas
menti ils ont voulu bien sûr quelque
part c'est un pli fier les explications
de texte quelque part et l'application
au stop qu'ovide effectivement elle
envoie aux serveurs beaucoup plus
d'informations que ce qui avait été
défini alors déjà une chose c'est que
cédric au n'a pas non plus démenti
puisque c'est quand même un chercheurs
de l'inria qui d'ailleurs était porteur
du projet stop qu'ovide qui qui a
découvert qui a découvert ça alors
qu'est ce qui se passe pour pour
expliquer clairement les choses
l'appli stop covit une application qui
est supposé est bien remontée des
informations par exemple pour une
personne qui est malade et bien on va
remonter au serveur l'ensemble des
contacts qu'elle croise et pas dans
n'importe quelle condition puisque
c'était supposé être fait lorsque la
personne était en contact avec quelqu'un
pendant plus de 15 minutes
et à moins d'un mètre alors déjà sur ces
sujets il ya déjà un problème parce que
à moins d'un mètre c'est très compliqué
de le savoir c'est que la technologie
qu'à utiliser c'est le bluetooth et
bluetooth permet pas de savoir à combien
m vous êtes et donc nécessairement ça
doit être ajoutée à des données de
géolocalisation
voilà pourquoi la piste up kovy de
demandes de la géolocalisation et puis
deuxième problème c'est les 15 minutes
alors on nous explique que toutes les 15
minutes également l'identifiant des
contacts change puisque ce sont supposés
être des identifiants anonyme ce qui
remonte normalement c'est pas des
données personnelles cd d'identifier
anonyme ça reste à vérifier et ses
identifiants changea ce serait la raison
pour laquelle est bien on fait remonter
ces informations en fait beaucoup plus
souvent que 15 minutes
en réalité c'est pas vraiment une bonne
raison parce que les appareils entre eux
qui parlent en bluetooth donc on pas
besoin d'un serveur sont capables de
gérer ce changement d'identifiant mais
vous voyez c'est un sujet un peu
technique et la réalité c'est qu'on a on
est développé cette application très
rapidement et donc forcément il ya des
choses qui n'ont pas été faites tout à
fait je dirais comme il aurait fallu et
comme en tout cas on le décrit ce c'est
une certitude
alors c'était des bords la polémique est
ce que l'application stop covit est en
danger pour la vie privée non c'est pas
un danger franchement c'est c'est quand
même fort de café de dire que ça
pourrait être un danger pour la vie
privée alors en revanche ce qui serait
un danger faut pas être naïf non plus ce
serait que l'état collecte des données
soit disant anonymes qui ne serait pas
bon ça il ya eu des vérifications quand
même qui ont été faites je crois que la
cnil a aussi regardé avec ce sujet avec
attention et c'est un organisme qui voit
là est suffisamment indépendant je pense
pour pour être pris au sérieux mais à la
fois voilà on peut faut pas non plus
être naïf les données même si elles sont
anonymisées bien on va savoir de quel
appareil elle remonte et donc in fine et
peut-être savoir de qui elle remonte le
vrai sujet c'est la collecte de masse
quand la collecte de masse se fait au
niveau d'une entreprise privée
je pense évidemment à toutes les
applications de réseaux sociaux que nous
avons tik tok facebook et c'est là ça ne
pose aucun problème aux citoyens - la
limite cd
reprise privée quand il s'agit d'un
organisme public une implication d'état
là c'est un service public est en
quelque sorte ça appartient aux citoyens
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya
une attention particulière sur ces
outils qui pourraient être déployées
peut-être pas pour pau pour le coc vide
mais des outils numériques qui serait
forcément une réponse à des crises
majeures il faut être très très prudent
ça c'est une évidence moi je note aussi
qu' on a eu le réflexe technophiles de
tout de suite dire on va faire une appli
qui va répondre aux besoins
franchement je moi je remets en cause ça
parce que en quoi cette application
mobile et est véritablement à la
diminution des cas et surtout après
finalement les forces de l'épidémie donc
il ya beaucoup de sujets la technologie
n'est pas forcément une réponse à tout
et ça il faut faire très attention avec
ça voilà donc on est sur une ligne de
crête où effectivement la technologie
aujourd'hui peut répondre à certains
enjeux mais il faut préserver nos
libertés c'est une évidence
et puis attention il faut être
transparent s'il s'agissait de dire ben
on remonte plus d'information plus de
contacts et fallait le dire
dire que les gens sont quand même libre
de télécharger cette application
heureusement c'est sur la base du
volontariat sont libres de déclarer
s'ils ont été atteintes non s'ils sont
malades non mais il faut de la
transparence et ce qui peut être
reproché aujourd'hui ça manque de
transparence
il n'y a rien il n'y a rien de pire
qu'un manque de transparence qu'un
changement de messages qu'ils puissent
décridibiliser voilà un gouvernement où
n'importe quel porteur de projet
monsieur forest merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
pdg de the whole earth est un réseau
social français qui n'utilisent pas les
données personnelles le sait
utilisateurs merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous